hello my name is James Wade and I'm a
research scientist at da a chemistry and
Material Science
company I'm also the maintainer of two
packages that let you use large language
models inside of our studio called GPT
studio and GPT tools today I'll show you
how you can use those but first I want
to start with a bit of a
concern
I'm worried that large language models
are a threat to the our
community but I hope to show you today
that we have both the power and the
obligation to shape how we use these
models to get our work
done I want to take us back to a little
over a year ago at the last our studio
comp when I look back at these pictures
I'm reminded of a few things for one the
The Masks remind me that the the
influence that the world around us has
on our own
Community the hex sticker wall reminds
me of all of the Fantastic AR
capabilities that make it such a
powerful tool built like by global open
source contributors developed by all of
us and standing there with my friends
and colleagues I'm reminded by what
makes this community so great it's the
people and it's the culture and even the
name itself
our studio comp reminds me that change
can happen change can be good but
sometimes change can be
scary like it or not large language
models are already everywhere if you
don't use them today it's likely that
you will be using them soon they're
being integrated directly inside the
tools that we use to do our jobs whether
we're data scientists developers sit in
meetings all day write email respond to
chats Microsoft 365 co-pilot is bringing
language models directly into tools like
teams Outlook word and PowerPoint and if
you're like me that covers a lot of what
you're using
day-to-day Google's duet AI is doing the
same thing for Google's work
workspace and even autocomplete features
in our text messages and emails are
bringing these models to our fingertips
by default whether we want them there or
not
these models are a big change for all of
us developers or not but my own
experience started with code
specifically it started with me using
GitHub co-pilot a large language model
powered tool that could help me write
code this was before the craze of chat
GPT but I was still quite excited by the
ability of a development environment to
fix my code give me new ideas and really
just lower the barrier to me making prog
progress on a data science project I was
so enamored by co-pilot that for a time
I actually switched away from the r
Studio IDE and instead was using visual
studio code I did that because that's
where I could access this tool and it
taught me that these models are
impacting not only how we work but where
we're doing that
work it's also worth noting that this
tool was not designed to help me write R
even though that's what I was using it
for it was designed for more popular
programming languages like python or
JavaScript but I still found it quite
useful to help me write my R
code I hadn't fully appreciated how
large language models were already
changing the way that I worked until the
demise of stack Overflow started
trending on Twitter now much like many
rumors of demise they were largely
overstated and the article that I have a
screenshot of on the slide here from the
stack Overflow team Fernly rebuts those
claims now for me I can tell you that
I'm using stack Overflow less and chat
gbt more I'm also encouraging colleagues
who are new to R to use large language
models so that they can overcome the
cumbersome challenges like syntax or
other peculiarities of learning to code
for the first
time this is where my concern for our
community comes
in what does it mean for us if those new
to r or code in general stop visiting
the community forums like stack Overflow
and the posit Community Forum instead
are going to chat GPT or other language
modelbased coding
tools what does it mean if the models
that are helping people learn to code
are much better helping them in
languages other than our
own well I'm here to tell you that the
use and the application of large
language models within the r Community
is wide
open now is for us to Define now is the
time for us to Define how we use these
tools and I hope to use today's talk to
give you some ideas towards just
that when you think of large language
models maybe you think abouts of
billions of parameters or trillions of
tokens whatever that architecture of a
transformer really is they can seem
Untouchable and complex I don't know
about you but I don't have tens of
millions of dollars to go train a new
one and so it can feel like there's not
much for us to do but when we think
about how we use large language models
they're actually quite simple we write a
prompt send it over to one of those
hundreds of billions of parameters
models and we get a response back making
simple tweaks to The Prompt like
including documentation from our
favorite packages or maybe even some
Snippets of code that you found useful
you can augment that prompt to get
better and better responses from those
models today's talk is going to focus on
us as the user of these tools and how we
can use them right inside the r Studio
environment and how we can use them to
make our work even better let's Dive
In I want to start with probably the
simplest example which is how you can
use a chat GPT like interface to query
open AI models right from inside of our
studio as you might imagine the first
thing we need to do is install a couple
packages those are GPT Studio use this
and mini UI once you've installed those
packages open up the r Environ file
using a convenience function inside of
the use this pack package edit our
Environ we'll use this to set our API
key which is how these apis know that
we're allowed to use them it provides
our authentication for us we'll be using
open AI for all of the tutorials today
but I also include examples from
anthropic the makers of Claude hugging
face which has many NLP models that you
can choose from and download locally as
well as Google's Palm model all of these
models can be used with it within the
GPT Studio
package once our API key is set and the
packages are installed we're ready to
use GPT Studio to do so go to the
add-ins Pane and type chat GPT inside
the search window you can click the chat
GPT which will launch a shiny app that
allows you to interact with the open AI
model so for this example here's the
prompt we're going to use Ed just to
show you how the package works it says
suppose you were analyzing the dialogue
from different Star Wars movies using
the Tidy text and deer packages how
would you determine which character
speaks the most frequently and create a
bar plot that Vis visualizes the 10 most
verbos characters as you can see the
response from the model streams in real
time and any code examples are
highlighted in in an isolated window
that you can click copy to take the code
paste it into maybe the con a source
document or maybe a Cordo document as
well the responses from this are much
like you would get from chat GPT so be
aware of things like hallucinations or
incorrect code and make sure you review
any code before you actually execute
it that example might be somewhat
familiar and and maybe even boring to
many of you in the audience today so
let's St step it up a notch beyond what
we could do with simply a chat GPT like
interface let's create our own chatbot
in fact let's create a Hadley wickom
chatbot I'll show you how you can do
that here's the prompt we'll use to
create our chatbot you are a code
assistant chatbot that answers questions
and writes code in the style of Hadley
Wickham your answers are py but
informative as the creator of the
tidyverse and chief scientist at posit
you favor tidyverse answers to code
questions you are not only answering
code questions but you were teaching our
users to become better programmers so to
add this prompt we'll open up the
settings pane of the app there's a
number of different options here we'll
go to task and select custom and then
we'll paste in that prompt that I just
read to you you'll notice there's many
more options than I'll have time to
cover today but I have a separate video
that you can go watch if you want to see
more of the more of the features in
detail so to see the the effect of this
let's copy the same prompt that we just
showed you and send it off to the model
uh with our system prompt with our hadly
chapot in toe it might take a little bit
of nuance to see some of the differences
here but we're getting a little bit of
of a different response and I'll have to
leave it to Hadley to decide if he
actually thinks that this is in the
style of him there's certainly an art to
crafting these prompts and creating
these chat bots so if this is something
that's interested to interesting to you
I encourage you to to go check it out
for yourself and try try a couple of
different prompts and and see how how
the responses vary as a result
okay so this gives you the response of
what a custom chatbot could look like
but of course there's more that we could
go do with this as well and for that
we're going to move from the GPT Studio
package over to GPT
tools a common challenge you'll find
when using large language models is that
their training data doesn't contain the
context that's important to answer the
question that you've just asked so
giving it missing information missing
context through a technique called text
embeddings or a vector database semantic
search there's a lot of different terms
for this but the basic idea is that we
want to give the model the information
that it was missing right inside the
prompt so that it can provide more
contextualized answers more accurate
answers to our prompts to do that we'll
use the package GPT tools and in
comparison to to GPT Studio GPT tools is
more experimental it's uh more likely to
break but it's also where you're going
to see some of the Cutting Edge
applications of large language models
inside of our studio so with that let me
show you how we can create text
embeddings of the Tidy verse style guide
or tidy design principles to extend our
Hadley Wickham
chatbot we'll need to install gbt tools
which we'll need to do from GitHub since
it's an experimental package and not yet
on cray you can use the package manager
pack to make this easy the code on the
slide shows you how pointing to James H
Wade slgp tools once you've installed
the package and assuming you've already
configured your API Keys like we showed
for GPT Studio you can then use the
function crawl to point to the Tidy
design principles URL that's design.
tidy verse. org this function will crawl
those web pages and create text
embeddings that we can then use for our
semantic Search
application let me show you how that
works now that we've created our
embeddings we can load the app by typing
in retrieval into our add-ins and
running chat GPT with
retrieval what this is going to do is
when the app loads we can type our
prompt into the box here so the prompt
is in this case what do I need to know
about writing tidy functions in R it's
going to take that prompt and create an
embedding a vector that it then can
match against the text that we just
scraped the answer that we'll get back
is now going to be contextualized with
the Tidy design
principles you can see the answer here
uh has some information that comes from
that document if you're familiar with it
things like consistent apis and avoiding
magical defaults might sound quite
familiar then at the bottom with the
sources here you can link back directly
to the original page that it used used
for the contextualization purposes here
so this gives you the answer um a
contextualized answer much better than
what you would get just by using the
default Chad GPT
Model A frustration I've often found
with using these large language models
to help me code is that they're pretty
much always out of date a an update will
be pushed to some of my favorite
packages and when I asked for help the
answer I get back from these models is
old and not really what I'm wanting to
use when I'm trying to push the edges of
some of these capabilities of course I
want the latest documentation and we can
use this text embeddings approach to
keep our keep chat GPT up to date with
all of our favorite packages let me show
you
how to keep our text embeddings for our
package documentation up to date we
first need to list our favorite packages
I have here a list of some of my
favorite packages as part of the Tidy
verse tidy models shiny some packages
for machine learning operations natural
language processing packages and
packages to interface with large
language models that list we can pass to
a function called get packages to scrape
which will look to see if there have
been updates to the package based off
the package version if it's out of date
you can then pass it to scrape package
sites that will take that list of
outdated packages scrape the
documentation and recreate your text
embeddings with the up-to-date documents
it does its best to not recreate text
embeddings for text it's already seen
before to be wise with its token
spending budget uh but it isn't perfect
and this is likely to be a somewhat
expensive operation I would estimate on
the order of maybe a dollar or a few
dollars uh if you're using the open AI
text embedding endpoint for this with
these updated packages you'll now get
your responses coming from the the uh
querying chat GPT that provides the
context for the latest and greatest from
your favorite
packages most of what I've focused on so
far is how we can use these large
language models for productivity tools
but I want us to think a little bit
beyond that and specifically I want to
give you two examp Professor Michelle
noard has taught me a lot he's the
original creator of the GPT GPT Studio
package and he welcomed me at first as a
co-author and eventually as maintainer
of the package Michelle taught me what
large language models can mean for
accessibility Michelle's dyslexic and
because of his dyslexia he finds that
tasks that others might find trivial
like writing academic text or even
crafting a trivial email to require deep
work and focus from him he takes issue
with critics of large language models
thinking that they only regurgitate
mindless English he says that these
people have no idea how incredibly hard
it is for me Michelle a dyslexic
non-native to produce passible
English in addition to his academic
duties Michelle is now training his own
RP specific coding models inspired by
the utility that he has found for his
dyslexia and wanting to extend that to
others I hope to share more on these R
specific models soon
another package co-author Samuel
Calderone a data analyst at the ministry
of the interior in Peru taught me about
the importance of language barriers in
learning to code in his experience
mentoring peers in Peru he found that
they would often give up if the source
documentation was not in their native
language finding it difficult to learn
both another spoken language while also
learning how to code because of his
insights the GPT studio app now includes
translations into Spanish and because of
another open source contribution German
as well to make it easier for others to
use but to also make them feel more
welcome in using the app I should also
note that Samuel is the reason that we
have streaming in the app these are only
two lessons and I'm sure that I have
many more to
learn now that's where you come
in these packages in addition to some
others like chatter or open AI if you
want want to make direct queries to the
open ai's API are still wide open they
each have singled digigit numbers of
contributors maybe a handful of issues
and a couple open pull
requests it's a wide open landscape for
you to contribute code and help Define
how we use these models if you don't
want to contribute code I strongly
encourage you to become users of some or
all of these
packages help us learn how we should use
these large language models to help us
get our work done help us make R the
best place to use these large language
models thank
you